real fast food should always grab your
attention with big gutsy flavors
fantastic aromas and be immediately
satisfying
it should also be easy to make and quick
to cook and real fast food doesn't get
much faster than my first dish
chicken stir fry with rice noodles
some of the best street food i've ever
eaten was in asia every one of those
little markets was filled with smells of
delicious food that all centered around
an asian staple noodles learn to cook
those properly and you'll be surprised
how quick and easy it is to knock off a
delicious dinner
first off we're gonna soak our noodles
now these are rice noodles into a bowl
and just pour the hot water
over the rice noodles
soak
and rehydrate
12 to 15 minutes to soften up if you've
got a wok perfect if not just a normal
size frying pan with big sloping sides
pan on
get it really nice and hot
chicken breast very lean hardly any fat
on there you've got this little fillet
just slice that off
now the secret to getting it really nice
and thin
and to cut it into strips
take your knife
keep it nice and flat on the board and
sort of slice it in half like a sort of
scallop
like that
we call this butterfly in the chicken
take a rolling pin
and nice and gently roll over the
chicken what it does it sort of flattens
it allows you to slice it
even thinner
and the thinner the slices of the
chicken
the sort of crispier it gets the quicker
it cooks
slice it in half
just start slicing
these nice
thin slices and the good news is one
chicken breast can serve two or three
easily
next wash your knife and finely slice
garlic
the thinner the garlic
the crispier
this is a
young
tender
broccoli just slice them down
i want a bite to the broccoli
and normally you sort of paste the dish
with one-third noodles one-third
vegetables and one-third of your protein
chicken
with a dish that takes literally minutes
to put together it's really important to
get everything organized everything
needs to be at your fingertips
touch
of olive oil
get a pan really nice and ready just
starting to smoke
drop the chicken in first
salt pepper
open up those little strands of chicken
nice
[Music]
once you've started to sear off the
chicken
get the garlic in
now let that get really nice and crispy
the way to do it is to sort of spread
all the chicken the garlic up the side
of the pan
and see why it's so important to cut the
chicken thin strips because it colors
and cooks at the same time as well
really really crucial
now that garlic's getting really nice
and crispy broccoli in
feels strange putting raw broccoli
in like that normally
we'll blanch it in boiling water dry it
out but
you want that crunch now soy sauce that
helps to season it but also stains
beautifully soy sauce in
lovely
it's exactly what i want now take that
out
give your pan a little wipe out
a little teaspoon of olive oil get that
wok
really nicely oiled again
drain your noodles
they're beautiful
this is a really exciting way of
finishing
this quick stir fry very classic two
eggs
in
[Music]
whisk up the eggs
and give that a really good whisk
[Music]
sort of almost
spread it
at the side of the pan
lightly season
the eggs
noodles
in
chicken and broccoli in
[Music]
and give
that
a really nice mix
you want the egg to sort of almost
bring the dish together
that egg's cooked
make sure you've got that nice
even distribution of
chicken
broccoli
garlic
[Music]
and lovely just finish that fresh lime
and then you have a very
simple
delicious stir-fry with rice noodles
[Music]
my next easy dish using the versatile
noodle is stir fried pork noodles
first marinade pork mince and shaoxing
rice wine a fortified chinese wine
soy sauce
and sesame oil
next fried chopped ginger in hot olive
oil
and garlic
[Music]
next add szechuan peppercorns which have
a wonderful lemony flavor and gives a
pleasant tingling sensation
now add your marinated pork mince
and brown
if you want more seasoning and extra soy
sauce
then add fiery chili bean paste
and rice wine vinegar
[Music]
add in cooked egg noodles
mix together
finally top with chopped spring onion
and toasted sesame seeds
[Music]
packed with flavor and on the table in
15 minutes delicious stir-fried pork
noodles
[Music]
you